I've never reviewed Dragon Ball Z and
it's not by accident on YouTube I'm
known as the guy that's reviewed one
piece Naruto bleach and many other
popular series I've even written
multi-hour long in-depth reviews for the
likes of Dragon Ball GT Dragon Ball
super all of the films and because I
valued my sanity I also covered classic
Dragon Ball all of these excursions were
massive projects that literally and
figuratively took me to my creative and
at times physical limits limits I was
pushing past so that someday I could
make this video the final Dragon Ball
Review series that's been five years in
the making a series I've saved for the
very end because it's where my career
began get excited and strap in folks
because this is going to be my longest
and most in-depth analysis to date where
I will push even further Beyond deliver
for all of you over the next month the
finale to a series I'm convinced is so
much better than Millions give it credit
for and finally talk about my childhood
favorite I hope you're sitting down
because this is everything I've got I'm
Mark Fitzpatrick and this is quite
simply a story that needs no such
introduction I am of course talking
about the global phenomenon the
instantly iconic and the exceptionally
exciting Akira toriyama's Dragon Ball Z
Lord Keep
[Music]
one
the Saiyan Saga
um
[Music]
as first acts go this introduction is
second to none in Dragon Ball no matter
which Arc you're talking about better
than anything GT super and even early
Dragon Ball offered this first step into
this Arc is pack 2 bursting with so much
lore swerves rug pulls reintroductions
introduction stipulation strategies
techniques old and new and sets up
what's to come in such a perfect way
that I would probably gush at numerous
points in this video uncontrollably as
to why it is so damn good and 100 that
case in point Goku's spiky older
brother Raditz so yeah Goku's an alien
and Toriyama is a weird but very fun
writer when it comes to this flight by
the seat of your pants type writing
style unlike series such as one piece or
attack on Titan which have justifiably
been celebrated in the past for their
Clear Vision they progressed through the
story with dragon ball is sort of the
opposite in pretty much every respect
Toriyama is a massive fan of injecting
comedy into his manga and that's fitting
because this dude pretty much improvised
an entire story that turned into one of
the cultural touchstones of my
generation no big deal and while
proceeding in that fashion is
unorganized and has its downsides I will
absolutely be getting into later there
are some upsides that really gave this
series an energy that otherwise couldn't
have existed without it in the same way
a crowd gets giddy when a comedian
quickly claps back at a Heckler in the
crowd we as readers of Dragon Ball can
appreciate the chaotic Blitzkrieg of
creative choices that takes place in
Dragon Ball and no opening to an arc
better exemplifies the upsides of this
approach than the kickoff to Dragon Ball
Z like take this one for example for
pages and Pages following raditz's
reveal he Bellows about the lack of work
produced by this quote Kakarot we've
never heard of this person's name before
so we assume it's a new character we
wonder to ourselves who the hell is he
talking about and right as he's leaving
his first encounter with Piccolo we get
this panel and with that one panel
Toriyama single-handedly turned the
entire Dragon Ball World onto its head I
can see it now the collective minds of
millions across Japan being blown and
while it wasn't built up to and while he
likely never planned for Dragon Ball to
take this particular course in the first
place he also tends to leave his stories
fringes vague when he doesn't know what
to write down and honestly that
restraint that ability to not feel like
he has to have all the answers all the
time that might be one of the secret
ingredients to this series unironically
it doesn't bloat any of the narrative
it's all for the purpose of keeping the
project streamlined certainly but it
also doesn't cut off any options for him
when he wants to take them I mean he
introduces Goku in the very first Arc of
Dragon Ball and people immediately start
to ask about his tail but Goku and
Toriyama they answer honestly about it
by not really giving that much
information because they don't really
know and that works because it isn't
important to the story and while this
does have its down downsides what this
more relaxed approach offers the series
is a unique flexibility to jump from a
Kung Fu adjacent genre to a sudden
sci-fi Galactic epic in the snap of his
fingers literally one chapter of
transition and it's seamless you accept
it immediately because of course he's an
alien he transforms into a giant monkey
and yes it's a monkey not an ape Apes
don't have tails ooga booga strong
monkey and speaking of monkeys can we
talk about the introduction of song
Gohan for one second but first let me
talk to you all about another Galactic
Tale one with awesome battles amazing
graphics and extra are cute anime girls
if that's your thing this is the global
hit space fantasy RPG honkai star rail
from the creators of genshin impact this
free to play game sees you embark on a
planet hopping Adventure aboard the
astral Express where you'll encounter a
stunningly rendered host of awesome
characters to build your team with as
you Trailblazers across this
meticulously constructed sci-fi World
available on both mobile and PC this
game Sports insane visuals on both
platforms thanks to its top tier
cinematography and animation Direction
whether it's cutscenes or the amazing
special effects in combat every moment
is a genuine audio visual feast and with
the release of this video you can now
pick up two new limited 5 Star
characters first up is blade a powerful
swordsman with the ability to obliterate
enemies at the cost of his own HP the
more damage he takes the higher damage
he deals next is Kafka a terrifying
antagonist with a close connection to
the main character this ruthless Katana
wielding killer is one of the game's
most anticipated characters and with the
release of the 1.2 update you'll be able
to experience so many fascinating
turning points as the game reaches the
climax of its current story arc there's
never been a better time to get started
and if you're new you can use my link
down below to download this game to get
your hands on an extra 50 Stellar Jade
just use my promo code on the screen
right now or scan my QR code and you're
good to go once again my Link's in the
description and it's entirely free
foreign
I think it's clear that Toriyama wanted
him to be as different from his father
as he could possibly muster which
importantly and interestingly is a vital
aspect of the story that informs not
just his role in this Arc but for the
most part informs a lot of the story
that he will ultimately tell in this
series but as introductions to a
character and as introductions to this
general idea broadly speaking goes I
don't think it could have been handled
any better it isn't often we get to
watch a main character grow up and then
be overshadowed by their children mostly
due to that Offspring always on some
level being compared to their fathers
and never living up to them and while
there is an element of this in Gohan
it's that very element that makes him as
fascinating as he otherwise ends up
becoming acting as a character study
that simultaneously highlights Goku's
strengths and eventually his weaknesses
and to achieve such a sophisticated
character Akira Toriyama wrote Gohan to
be in almost every area area of this
character's personality the total
opposite to Goku and to see this you
need not to look any further than their
introductions if we cast our minds back
to the opening of dragon Ball's first
Arc for Goku he's entirely independent
confident practices martial arts is
incredibly strong a little rough around
the edges when it comes to his manners
and even saves Bulma after their first
meeting immediately his role is clear to
us he's a capable hero but if we look at
Gohan's introduction he's incredibly shy
hides behind his father doesn't know how
to fight appears helpless is polite
Beyond his years and doesn't save
someone but instead gets kidnapped
himself this establishes Gohan
immediately as an entirely different
character and entity to that of his
father but there is something more there
than just a helpless crying child and
that search for that hero inside of
himself is Central to Gohan's entire
story in Dragon Ball Z a journey that
begins in his Rangers space pod on a
grassy barren field somewhere on Earth
as he awaits his heroic fathers rescue
Goku and Piccolo vs Raditz that right
there was probably my favorite quote
from Goku during the Saiyan Saga on its
face it's a rather innocuous lion that
speaks to Goku's disagreeing with his
brother's assessment of him and his
abilities but for me at least this one
line represents the prevailing theme of
not just this Arc but perhaps this
entire story Raditz is a character that
is present in the beginning of this
story but is quickly forgotten however
for me he represents what is my favorite
story told in Dragon Ball a story of
expectations versus reality nature
versus nurture and allyship versus
selfish Conquest I spoke on this
generally with toriyama's introduction
to Gohan moments ago but the same is
true for Raditz in this fight and indeed
the other Saiyans that make their
presence felt later on in the story they
are designed to represent an
antithetical ideology and culture to
that of Goku in order to highlight his
differences his weakness this is sure
but also indeed his strengths even
beyond that if we look at the scouter an
iconic piece of tech that radath
introduces to the story while these
metrics are fun to speculate on and mess
around with in private or with friends
online the entire point of the scouter's
introduction with this story is to
provide yet another metric by which the
earthlings understand what true power is
and how Raditz and indeed the other
forces of frieza's army are misguided
ironically that true power comes from
manipulation of key group strategy and
specific martial arts proficiency rather
than brute force and strength alone
you'll notice that those with discolors
devices that are designed to give the
wearer a better idea of what they're
seeing are in fact the most blind on the
battlefield in the case of Raditz he's
taken off guard not once not twice not
even three times but at numerous
instances to varying degrees of severity
this scouter Raditz relied on put him on
the back foot and caused him to
underestimate Piccolo and perhaps most
crucially his brother Goku
[Music]
this fight is perfect sure it's not as
good as other major fights in the story
or even this Arc but it was never
designed to be this fraternal conflict
instead is here to set the stage for
what's to come next and to establish the
theme of The Ark as a whole that theme
being the differences we are criticized
for can be our greatest strengths and
you need look no further for validation
of this sentiment than this battle here
with Raditz criticized chastised and
taken advantage of for acting contrary
to the ruthless Warrior Raditz claims
all Saiyans should naturally be
Goku stands in opposition to him and
this ideology by rejecting his offer
allying himself with his greatest enemy
surprising him with a technique he
learned from a dear friend and mentor
and finally defeats him with the help of
Piccolo in what is the most selfless act
he's offered in this series so far and
honestly quite brilliantly Raditz could
never have seen this move coming because
Raditz could never foresee a world where
he would do the same for anyone else in
more ways than one raditz's worldview
limited his abilities all the while Goku
because of his sacrifices and virtues
has a community of friends supporting
him that will March quite literally to
hell and back in order to bring him back
from the brink
earlier on I claimed that this First Act
does a lot but in reality it does
everything it changes the atmosphere of
the entire story retroactively while not
contradicting anything it establishes a
brand new main character for us to
follow in Gohan provides a captivating
angle or theme from which to digest this
story through and sets up countless
other facets to the story all the while
demonstrating one of the most Breakneck
tightly paced fights in the series and
did I mention that the main character
dies an interesting and frankly morbid
piece of trivia concerning this
chapter's release is that one month
following it Emperor Hirohito died and
one month following that the father of
manga himself Osama tezuka passed away
also so in reality over the course of a
little over 2.5 months the Japanese
public had been shocked by a tragic
passing following Goku's first ever
death in the manga and with three
prolific figures of the time having
passed the start of 1989 was was a
turbulent one for Japan so yeah this
fight is everything everything on a much
smaller scale than what is admittedly
right around the corner is prefaced in
this fight and serves as the perfect
launch pad and I think a lot of that
gets Lost in Translation because of how
many people start Dragon Ball with the
first Arc of Z it's easy to forget that
this fight isn't just the story of Goku
but a vital chapter also in the story of
Piccolo and his gradual shift in
standing with the main cast once the
most overwhelming villain to have ever
graced the Dragon Ball world now
unlikely allies with his arch nemesis
Goku against a formidable foe from the
Stars
Piccolo's change is slow but it is
seismic and just as we think that we've
got our feet under us following raditz's
impactful entry and exit stage left
Gohan is kidnapped by the greatest super
villain this world has ever seen for
special training for as it happens
thanks to the scouter Raditz was wearing
his allies the Saiyans are arriving in a
single gear all the while Goku the
Earth's hero is hurled into what will
soon become my favorite setting in all
of Dragon Ball
other world
but before we move on just a quick heads
up that I have a huge announcement later
on in this video so stay tuned
second acts in stories training arcs and
tournament arcs neither of which dragon
ball is in particularly short supply of
and in this particular second act there
are two main plot lines to follow as
well as the looming threat on the
horizon driving all the action that's
taking place so let's start with my
favorite one Otherworld and the Wacky
Adventures of Goku on the way to train
with King Kai you know what training Arc
is going to be good when in order to
qualify for said training you need to
one be dead two be one of the lucky few
actually chosen to travel with their
physical bodies in the first place and
three Traverse a seemingly Endless 1
million kilometer road that has only
once been crossed in the last 100
million years this is a smaller side but
unironically snake way as well as Goku's
Journey on it has been one of the main
Inspirations as to why I started running
marathons in the first place it's a
simple but immensely effective Visual
and physical challenge for us to
understand as readers not to mention a
fun one visually it's striking with the
clouds beneath acting as an abyss the
likes of which threaten to swallow up
Goku if he misses so much as a single
step and in addition to all of that it's
contrasted with this look that just
screams let's do it as soon as he heads
off flying and for whatever reason this
scene has always stuck in my head as
sort of this encapsulation of exactly
what I love about Goku and as a kid it
was always something I tried to take
inspiration from that there will be
seemingly impossible challenges ahead
but all of those challenges if you
approach them with the right attitude
you really can handle them Goku is a
character I love and this environment
really dragged out some of my favorite
qualities of his and that's not even to
mention the filler in the original
broadcast either and while I will remain
consistent and say that I don't
typically enjoy filler and that if
you're looking for a pure experience as
the original author intended you should
read the Manga or go watch Kai or
something with all that said these
episodes are still some of my favorite
fillers of all time pulling the trigger
on Goku falling into hell only to find
himself in a series of challenges
against these two Long Heads was a great
idea and the misdirection of Princess
snakes Palace only further elevated the
treacherous path Goku had to navigate on
his way to King Kai's training but the
street cleaner gag is just too perfect I
cannot help but imagine that akinatorama
wish and was kicking himself for not
having come up with it himself it's just
too perfect and it might be my favorite
visual gag of all time
whenever I read this manga or watch
through this story I'm always struck by
how wonderfully Gohan's Journey
contrasts his father's original path as
a child all the while Goku gleefully and
resolutely marches down an impossible
path His Son Gohan is struggling to do
the very basics of survival even with
the help of an unlikely babysitter
casting her Minds back yet again we can
recall what Goku's first significant
on-screen training was as a child after
demonstrating his abilities and proving
himself worthy of Master Roshi's
tutelage Goku chose to willingly seek
out the guidance and training of who was
at the time the earth's greatest hero
contrast that now with Gohan someone who
too was chosen based on the merits he
demonstrated but was kidnapped forced to
take the training of not the Earth's
hero but instead its ultimate villain
and I honestly enjoyed noticing these
little choices because it clearly
demonstrated that from the the very
beginning Gohan was never meant to be
like Goku which is I found not only
interesting as a character study but
additionally as I found offered the
series something it otherwise hadn't in
any meaningful capacity prior looking
back on the early Dragon Ball series
there were of course plenty of
opportunities for us to share time with
Goku as he trained with various
individuals and Masters we've seen him
train with people like Krillin but
outside of his direct involvement any
secondary characters training took place
off screen Goku needed to be present in
order for us to see their training for
the most part however this time around
in the Saiyan saga no such mistreatment
of secondary characters takes place this
time mostly in the past this was the
Goku show but something is different
this time around and it's thanks to
Gohan who now assumes a comfortable and
natural position in the B plot not just
helping the pacing of this Arc
tremendously not just offering up screen
time to the likes of Piccolo who has up
until now only shared the screen with
Goku but it is the first indication
we've gotten that signals the importance
of the Gohan character moving forward
and how in more ways than one Dragon
Ball Z isn't simply the story of Goku
it's the rise of Gohan
[Music]
foreign
something of note also is that while I
referred to Gohan's training under
Piccolo as the beat plot earlier it's
worth noting that for the time being it
could be quite easily considered the a
plot with Gohan's training standing at
three chapters worth of material
compared to Goku's 1.5 chapters of total
time spent on kinkai's planet however
it's hard to shake the feeling that
Goku's time spent on King Kai's planet
was exceptionally special or at least it
was for me it's the first training Arc I
ever watched personally I loved it but
what's interesting is that it's the
first one for Goku on screen in quite
some time too while in the past Goku had
training with roshi and Kami and
technically his grandpa Gohan prior to
the series this training we see and
enjoy on this small but memorable planet
is the first piece of training we're
privy to as audience members for Goku
since his training alongside Krillin
with Master roshi in the second Arc of
the story that's ages ago and as
training goes it's near perfect firstly
kinkai is hilarious much the same way
roshi was an eccentric wise old teacher
King Kai follows suit with 100 less
horny those of you who know me will
understand why I vastly prefer King Kai
secondly King Kai's planet is the first
use of enhanced gravity in the series
for the purpose of training making it a
Natural Evolution on the weighted
clothing idea introduced in early Dragon
Ball and thirdly as I mentioned only 1.5
chapters worth of training is spent with
Goku on kinkais which Honestly made me
reflect on why I felt so strongly about
this material as a highlight of the
series and then it hit me much of the
actual on-screen training we get from
King Kai is just comedic relief very
good comedic relief at that but still
just comedic relief the actual training
we do get is classic Dragon Ball however
meaning it is all about the fundamentals
traditionally that has been toriyama's
approach with training in this series
but its use here Works exceptionally
well when you take into consideration
the broader context of the Ark in other
words when you take into account its
themes right around the corner is a
battle of good versus evil of elite
versus lower class of natural Talent
versus hard work outside of catching
bubbles almost all of Goku's technique
training with King Kai is kept
surprisingly vague and secretive given
that we as an audience are present to
watch him train in more than one instant
we hear some non-specific Talk of the
Kaioken and then Goku firing what
appears to be a key blast but all of
these moments are intentional this
withdrawing this withholding of
information is intentional these moments
are all planting seeds allowing these
crops to be harvested in Spades once
Goku reaches Earth
and similarly the vast majority of the
other individuals training including
Gohan at this point in time are also
kept largely off-screen further planting
seeds for the eventual yield that will
result in their first encounter with the
Saiyan okay actually wait there's one
piece of filler that I'm glossing over
and honestly it was the part of the show
I never enjoyed watching and that was
Gohan's extra episodes spent with those
orphan children and other training
hijinks at first glance this section of
the story seems perfect for filler
Misadventures the same way Goku's trip
across snake way offered but as I
mentioned the choice to avoid
demonstrating training is still a
creative choice and one that the anime
decided to change that in my opinion
serve to not only kill the pacing but
also somewhat spoil the confidence that
Gohan would eventually be demonstrated
to have gained along his way too
thank you
the Saiyan invasion
we'll be right back and now for the
exciting news many of you will know of
or may even contribute to my patreon at
this point up until now it's mostly just
being a way for you guys to directly
support me of your own volition but now
for the first time ever it is evolving
we are completely overhauling it not
only is it a great way to help the
channel but you will now be able to gain
access to a wide variety of awesome
exclusive perks we've got amazing
wallpapers for PC and mobile based on
the great artwork I've had made for the
channel over the years and these now
come with time lapses of their creation
too alongside this you'll gain access to
not only uncensored versions of the
videos but you'll be able to watch in
progress previews as soon as they're
finished during the week no more waiting
for YouTube but a big part of this is
really about connecting with you guys
and ensuring the most passion of you
have your voices heard we'll be taking
video suggestions from you guys as well
as producing an exclusive q a video
every single month and of course it
wouldn't be complete without a series of
my incredibly embarrassing outtakes that
my crew sure love to laugh at every
single week
exetting her newly acquired pit bit
so please head over to my patreon Linked
In the description and see what tiers
work best for you and either way your
contribution will now result in your
name featured at the end of our videos
as a way to recognize you and say thanks
this channel wouldn't be possible
without you guys and I hope this patreon
serves as a great place to support one
another with these awesome rewards I
can't wait for you guys to see some of
them
[Applause]
I've been waiting to talk about this one
for a long time Napa and Vegeta set a
bold new standard for this series in
this Arc gone are the days of camp
pageantry or gag fuel bosses with
humorous underlings Vegeta and Napa are
cold-blooded killers and Tori Amo wants
you to understand what this means for
Our Heroes right out the gate as they
effectively glass an entire city and
while this might be a rather climactic
statement made in this scene by dusting
this entire town of life it comes packed
with some subtle Exposition and insight
also firstly tension is built through
our Newfound understanding of the sane
homeworld's gravity situation these are
monstrously quick and savagely strong
foes secondly I like how they allude to
Gohan's power being one of the two two
most substantial power readings based on
their initial scouter scans furthermore
these expectations for Gohan are only
further emphasized when Krillin himself
upon his arrival on the battlefield
Compares Gohan with his father when he
was a kid this sets an interesting
expectation for us as readers because
aside from seeing a more confident Gohan
surviving in the wild at times we've not
really seen how he performs in combat
since his run-in with Raditz and while
I'm on the topic of Gohan I do like that
at every available opportunity he
dissuades people's expectations of
Piccolo as this Maniac or Monster of
evil like Goku he sees him for who he is
not what he projects and thematically
there's a lot there in terms of being
who you are versus what you're expected
to be similar to how Goku is who he is
without fear Piccolo at this present
time is conflicted somewhat even if he
doesn't show it the sudden Exposition
onto Piccolo from Vegeta and Napa
certainly takes him by surprise
concerning his ancestry
and the final piece of subtle Exposition
from the Saiyans is a key aspect of
Vegeta's characterization that is
communicated early and that is his
intelligence he recalls the name of the
dragon balls instantly points out how
Reckless nappa's glassing of an entire
city was because it could have contained
a dragon ball and Beyond even that
Vegeta is the first to acknowledge
almost immediately how worthless the
scouters themselves are based entirely
on raditz's encounter with the
earthlings prior it's terrific stuff and
demonstrates to us that while Vegeta
might be more monstrous than Napa in
every metric shocking as that may be
he's also double threatening because he
possesses the ability to abstractly
think on the Fly and compose strategy
based on available scarce information
but that's enough Preamble it's time to
start fighting
thank you
oh
I think the choice of using the Cybermen
is sort of emblematic of how Vegeta and
Napa View and value strength in the
story they each see the Earth's Fighters
aside from Piccolo because he's sort of
a namekian as weaklings these folks are
born on Earth destined to be weak
despite their efforts conversely the
Saiyans carry themselves around with
this over-inflated sense of
self-importance specifically because of
their ancestry because they know that
they are this strong naturally they are
born this way they cannot fathom
elements like teamwork specific martial
arts practice or technique and heart
playing any sort of meaningful role in
battle and so planting these Cybermen
beings that grow from the ground with no
experience no martial arts training and
no sense of self only highlight how this
is all the Saiyans believe is valuable
in fighting in other words the raw
strength that you're born with however
much to their surprise each one of the
Earth's Fighters defeats their
respective in one-on-one combat 10
shinhan in seconds absolutely dismantles
his Cybermen with little to no effort
much to Napa and Vegeta's shock and
surprise
because he was bested Vegeta kills him
mercilessly without consideration for
anything beyond his ability to fight or
lack thereof citing that because he was
defeated he no longer served any purpose
quote the earthlings already defeated
him it would have been a waste of time
even Yamcha technically possessed more
than the necessary power to defeat his
Cybermen it was only when he let his
guard down he was taken aback by this
creature's lack of humanity lack of
self-preservation and its immense
conviction to only care about the result
and not itself which again speaks to
this philosophy the Saiyans have
regarding power it's all that matters to
them nothing else is important reflected
in how the Cyberman carelessly treats
its own well-being its life is
meaningless it's just a number a meat
Shield that serves a basic function to
kill to fight to win because of this it
stands to reason why someone like Yamcha
who doesn't at all view the world this
way is taken off guard by this Kamikaze
play as is every single last one of the
Earth's Fighters including Piccolo much
to the joy of Vegeta who laps up this
strategic Ploy Yamcha gets a lot of
mockery following this display and
honestly it's a funny meme but in the
story the point of the scene is to
highlight that this was something none
of the Earth's Fighters could have
foreseen coming by virtue of how they
value other things Beyond just winning
it could have and likely would have
happened to many or any of them prior to
this stepping up to the plate Yamcha
told Krillin that he'd go first as he
could be wished back to life given that
Krillin didn't have that same luxury
being brought back in Dragon Ball arcs
prior and once the Cyberman
self-destructs Krillin reflects on this
sacrifice insinuating that this would
have been him had Yamcha not been so
considerate of his friend's fate so in
actuality while this scene is remembered
as yet another slip up by Yamcha
ultimately he's taking one for the team
at absorbing a blow that could have
unlikely would have taken each and every
one of them off guard if they were in
that same position a selfless sacrifice
and one that draws out of Krillin the
Earths secret power
[Music]
missing one it launches at Gohan who
despite what he just saw is totally
Frozen all this training all this
preparation all this anticipation and he
freezes in a wonderful moment of
guardianship Piccolo demonstrates his
ability and watchful eye of Gohan by
quickly disposing of this remaining
Cybermen and while also a wonderful
demonstration of why Yamcha taught him
with his sacrifice it is also our first
indication that unlike his father
Gohan is not ready for this not even
close however this doesn't stand out too
much at this point because well everyone
is taken off guard and Paralyzed by what
takes place next
[Music]
frightening as this move is with an
intensity of visual Carnage to rival
anything we've seen so far in this
series this scene's thematic highlight
and clever contrast comes not through
ten shinhan but instead through his
longtime friend and partner choutsu
[Music]
my quick breakdown earlier of the
philosophy behind yancha's Cyberman
Kamikaze was partially to illustrate
what the Saiyans believe in order to
establish a clear contrast between them
and the forces of Earth however there
was a secondary purpose and it was for
this scene right I mentioned that one of
the aspects that took Yamcha off guard
was his inability to conceive of this
particular strategy from this invading
evil force in other words Yamcha was too
good too loving of a person with too
much to live for where he would so
frivolously cast his side his life like
that a cursory glances attack on Napa
might appear to share many of the same
parameters but truthfully it is again a
terrific highlight of this difference
that exists between the Saiyans and the
earthlings when the Cybermen attacked
out of instinct and fear of consequence
attacking with a singular goal chaosu's
attack is one of desperation to save
everyone like Yamcha his is a sacrifice
born out of a desire to prevent more
pain coming to his friends by giving up
everything and Napa just like Yamcha for
the opposite reasons never solve this
attack coming in other words where
Yamcha was too good of a person Napa was
so bought into this idea of Might makes
right and power is all that matters that
he couldn't foresee anyone let alone
himself doing something like chaotsu did
for his friends that day it's another
spectacular narrative choice that
carries with it so much meaning and
thematic significance both yancha and
chaotsu offered up their lives and in
doing so not just save their friends
momentarily but through this leverage of
their characters Akira Toriyama was able
to establish concretely what these
Saiyans are heartless monsters with no
value for anything or anyone beyond
their own selfish interest and in the
case of the earthlings while not enough
to stop Vegeta or Napa they are
certainly much more than either of the
two cruel Saiyans ever imagined they
possibly could be Piccolo isn't yet
fully bought into this idea of
self-sacrifice however and part of him
still wants to believe that he's Bad to
the Bone and I think because of that
despite being shocked just as bad as
everyone else as he watches what unfolds
with these Fallen Warriors He's also the
only one able to retain a semblance of
timing and strategy and thankfully he
too can bring those like Krillin and
Gohan into his plan of action a plan
that actually looks as though it's going
to work writers Napa is about to kill
ten chinhan Piccolo gives the signal
before disappearing suddenly and
reappearing right before Napa Landing
his own brutish animalistic slash Miss
Claus onto the brutal and heinous Saiyan
following this the seasoned Earthling
Krillin matches his effort with his own
clubbing strikes setting up Gohan for
the Perfect final attack the strategy
was perfect the strongest of the Earth's
Fighters sets up the attack with what is
the most dangerous part confronting Napa
directly following this Krillin someone
who can be relied on in a pinch one who
earned Piccolo's respect in arcs prior
during the 23rd Tenkaichi budakai Nails
his role here also and now hurtling
towards Gohan the second strongest
fighter from Earth
[Music]
he freezes because of course this
happened unlike Piccolo unlike Krillin
and unlike even Goku this isn't Gohan's
Natural State standing on the
battlefield with monsters forced to Bear
witness to graphic deaths and attacks
time and again almost coming close to
dying himself this was always going to
be the outcome because as I've mentioned
time and again in this video Gohan isn't
special or interesting because of his
abilities but instead his lack of them
and his determination to keep trying
despite this natural aversion he has to
fighting and danger
[Music]
in the blink of an eye this small and
scared five-year-old child has watched
three allies all die in horrific and
tragic fashion it's worth noting that
earlier I mentioned Piccolo was the
strongest of the Earth's forces and that
Gohan was second however I said that
only really because it was what Napa and
Vegeta assumed based on their initial
readings at the time and who they
discovered once they arrived to
investigate but as it happens Gohan
according to Piccolo has greater power
dwelling within him than even he
possesses this juxtaposition between
Gohan's latent ability and his desire to
avoid conflict at all costs is a match
made in heaven narratively speaking
placing a tremendous amount of Hope and
responsibility on his capable but small
and unsure shoulders is the perfect
recipe for manufacturing tension and
exciting moments however before we get
to that the Saiyans and by Saiyans I
mean Vegeta recognizes that Gohan
Piccolo and krillin's talk of Goku must
mean Kaka is soon to arrive and giddy to
torture his son before his very eyes
they jump at the chance to give the
saying traitor Kakarot the time he needs
to reach the battlefield but three hours
pass and he still doesn't show up from
this point on every single moment has
been showcasing another one of the ark's
themes that being the earthling's
unwillingness to give up from Piccolo's
failed plan against Napa to Gohan
miraculously withstanding Napa's full on
attack to Krillin still managing to get
an attack off against Napa the remaining
three Fighters continue endlessly in
their Endeavor to fight back despite how
obviously beaten they are it's a level
of determination against adversity that
not only befuddles Napper to the point
of Rage but is in the end a driving
force that is pivotal to the eventual
victory of Earth as a whole that drive
to carry on despite adversity is an
attitude that both Napa and Vegeta are
completely alien too they were born into
a higher class and from what has been
indicated to us thus far have likely
largely bulldozed over pretty much every
fold they've ever faced up until now in
other words there is no obstacle for
them to overcome normally they are the
obstacle but that difference in
perspective is what makes all the
difference here and just plays even more
into the themes of the upcoming fight
against Vegeta the themes of class of
the Resolute strength that the
earthlings lower class status has
instilled in them ensuring they will
continue training and fighting back
until their final breath Piccolo said it
best the Earth doesn't go down easily
and he's saying that from experience and
that's when it happens Goku arrives at
the check-in station to find Kami as
he's transported to the land of the
living once again and the moment Goku's
body arrives in that realm Vegeta's
scouter surges into action alerting him
to something they never expected it
reads a power level of 5 000 closing in
on their location shocked he orders Napa
to kill them all immediately while this
wasn't to be expected I love that Vegeta
has the wherewithal to assess the
situation and strategize with a limited
time before kakarot's imminent arrival
he concludes that with earthlings
appearances can be deceiving and if
Kakarot was raised here too that means
that he also could be hiding something
more than what was initially read on the
scouters odds are if these earthlings
could help Kakarot things could prove
challenging for the Saiyans I mean
Vegeta's awareness compared to Napa here
is chilling but exhilarating to watch
foreign
it's remarkable how exciting this was to
read through it's just handled so
perfectly time and again we're always
given more of a reason to hold on to
hold out just one moment longer and man
you might not register this upon your
first reader watch but this is the first
attack Gohan has level against these
Invaders it's his first attack and it's
by far the most significant on Napa thus
far and he knows it
see there
this might be the most significant point
in the story so far everyone is down
Goku isn't here and Gohan is face to
face with the strongest attack leveled
against anyone thus far in the entire
series the only one who seems to have
the strength to make it to his feet is
Piccolo and as the son of his lifelong
enemy faces certain death Piccolo drops
the last remaining facade of evil and
steps head first into a new era of his
character as he gives up his life for
another
[Music]
foreign
it cannot be overstated how powerful
this moment is for most of us in the
English-speaking world the Z anime was
our first experience with this story
which means that just shy of 40 of the
story was missing to us and as a result
much of the Saiyan arcs bombshell
moments such as these are muted in the
grand context of the series one moment
were introduced to Goku and the next
were told he's an alien one moment were
introduced to Piccolo and told he was a
villain before we see he's good again or
at worst an anti-villain the pieces are
there but the sheer weight of what the
first 40 of the story provided is not
Piccolo's sacrifice here is one of
dragon Ball's finest character moments
it's the culmination of a character Arc
spanning so many volumes and it's a
moment Toriyama spends so much time
building to in this Arc alone this is a
character born with the sole desire to
kill Son Goku and more than that was
born with this goal specifically in mind
one inherited from his creator and won
evidence with malicious Force as he
mercilessly broke all of Goku's limbs in
their first iconic battle but this Arc
changes everything killing Goku in this
battle against Raditz technically
achieves Piccolo's goal but it's never
seen as such nor is it presented that
way in fact Piccolo complements Goku's
prowess in the battle and he uses his
death as merely a means to rile up
Raditz by reminding him Goku will live
again the change is already clear at
this point but as Piccolo takes Gohan
away to train him this transition in
alignment only becomes stronger to the
point that God himself actively tells us
this is the case in fact arguably before
Piccolo even realizes it himself
throughout Gohan's training Piccolo is a
brutal Master on the surface he leaves
go on defend for himself but still takes
the time to leave him apples he removes
Gohan's tailor for the sake of removing
a weakness but follows up with clothing
and a weapon every dark moment is
followed by one of tenderness and by the
time the battle rolls around their
chemistry is strong to the point of
being referred to collectively we've
become far stronger and as Napa faces
Gohan Piccolo makes a choice he casts
aside not just his life but the dragon
balls too he puts aside everything for
this child he is nurtured and bonded
with over the last several months and
gives up his life instead and it's at
this moment the facade drops what God
realized months ago finally comes
pouring out of Piccolo's own mouth Gohan
changed him quote you were the only one
who ever really talked to me that
familial path he was set on by his
creator was disrupted by the sheer
innocence and love of a child a running
theme in this Arc is that of bucking
existing expectations based on this idea
of inherited responsibility others
having expectations of Gohan as Goku's
firstborn son Goku learning he's in many
ways the antithesis of what the Saiyans
represent in the cosmos and Piccolo in a
similar fashion we can see has struggled
with his own identity the issues since
his arrival in the story this sort of
messaging is all over this Arc even
going as far as to subvert our own
expectations of certain characters take
Gohan for example son of the main
character and his very first key blast
his first signature technique isn't a
Kamehameha it's a move from Piccolo a
move literally called masenko or demon
flash this is all to say that the
message of this Arc has always been that
who we are is not and should not be
dictated To Us by our Race by our
culture or our relatives in the same way
Goku was demonized by rats for being
unlike how he viewed a Saiyan should be
Piccolo 2 was born with expectations and
believed he needed to live up to those
expectations as they were his life's
greatest purpose he even believed it but
as pointed out by Gohan his father would
tell him that Piccolo wasn't ever really
a bad person like King Piccolo was
before him and firsthand Gohan
discovered that Piccolo was quite the
opposite to how many had described him
before and that's what this moment is a
culmination of everything a final Act of
defiance against who he expected himself
to be in order to be true to who he is
no longer living a lie instead choosing
to Die the hero it is genuinely one of
toriyama's finest character moments and
a real Triumph in an arc full of
incredible scenes
hmm
this is what relief feels like Toriyama
has given us so much in this Arc placed
our point of view unto Gohan formed new
bonds with unlikely Heroes demonstrated
the tenacity of Earth in more ways than
one and systematically has torn down and
taken away each and every one of these
culminating with and teasing the final
nail in the coffin Gohan's ultimate
defeat and death at the hands of Napa
only to remind us that this is still
Goku's story
there's something to be said for how
Goku arrives on the battlefield during
the Saiyan Arc and while it's
effortlessly cool to watch this offbeat
somewhat lighthearted character
nonchalantly walls from one side of the
battlefield to the next without so much
as acknowledging Vegeta or Napa's taunts
and jeers in a way by virtue of being
true to his own values by being silent
by focusing first and foremost on his
friends showing sentiment and concern
for their well-being Goku's attitude by
default flies in the face and insults
the Saiyan way of life it immediately
communicates to us as readers what this
situation really is at this point Goku
has so astronomically surpassed Napa he
isn't even really a concern to him and
while Napa sees this as Goku having a
Death Wish rather than a concern for his
loved ones we as readers know otherwise
it sets up this level of impending
catharsis or should I say impending beat
down that only Goku can deliver once
again again Goku by being who he is
rejects the supposed way of life Vegeta
and Napa represent
[Applause]
foreign
much like Piccolo Goku was believed to
have been sent to this world to conquer
it to kill to ravage to enslave but that
wasn't who Piccolo was and as Napa is
quickly finding out that isn't who Goku
is either tunapa sentiment Mercy
consideration for others are all signs
of weakness weakness that leads him to
vastly underestimate Goku when he first
engaged with him
what's so fascinating about this fight
is that it actually marks an important
shift in Akira toriyama's philosophy if
you cast your minds back to the pre-z
portion of the story Goku's small
demeanor was used to create David versus
Goliath type moments the smaller power
besting Giants so to speak whether it be
King Piccolo or Sergeant metallic Goku's
small stature and excitable personality
was pitted against these huge menacing
foes and Goku's fight against Napa is an
awesome one and follows the same
approach just look at how small Goku is
pictured against this guy only to style
on him again and again and again with
Toriyama breaking out some of the more
Dynamic and fun angles in his toolkit
it's a short but incredibly cathodic
bout that's been much needed amidst all
that was lost but it's here that Akira
Toriyama flips the design philosophy on
its head Vegeta a tiny Speck of a man
ruthlessly obliterates Napa in an
instant the smaller of the pair is by
far the most powerful and in spite of
Goku's bout against Napa serving to show
us just how much he's improved this
surprise moment this switch up in design
philosophy not only brutally brings
reality crashing back down around us but
it also reminds us that this isn't the
same happy-go-lucky Dragon Ball we all
know and love anymore from frieza's
tiniest form being his most Mighty to
the same being true for cell and of
course the minuscule evil boo really
slams this philosophy home it's a simple
but effective switch and conveyance of
power and man it's sure does nicely set
the stage for arguably the greatest
clash in the history of Shonen manga
I have touched exclusively on the manga
so far because I've always been of the
mind that approaching the story in its
purest form right from the author is the
best way to examine a story but this is
Dragon Ball Z I would imagine almost all
of us got into this series through the
anime whether it be on Toonami back in
the day or through Kai if you're part of
the Next Generation it's a cultural
landmark of a series and the staff who
put it together are just as important to
its worldwide success as Akira Toriyama
himself and so I want to take you on a
journey with the staff who made this
show a reality explore their Styles and
how their hierarchy changed across the
show's seven years on the air yep that's
right seven years there there's no way
that could be right you see in spite of
the big toy animation logo slapped right
on the show Dragon Ball Z was
predominantly outsourced to a large
number of subcontracted Studios while
towie is a colossal Mammoth of a
production house these days back in the
day they straight up lacked the Manpower
needed to produce a weekly show like
Dragon Ball entirely in-house in other
words they needed a lot of help for the
San Arc alone that we're covering today
there are six Studios to introduce and
by the end of the series that number
will have doubled to 12. Dragon Ball Z
is one massive collaborative project of
varying quality and that quality is
almost entirely determined by the studio
that I've worked on it each given week
first up is Studio Junior perhaps one of
the most important of those introduced
today this studio was led by the very
character designer of the show my noru
Maeda this man has been with the series
since the very beginning serving as the
character designer for both the doctor
slump anime before Dragon Ball as well
as the original dragon series his
ability to mimic toriyama's art during
this era was really second to none and
the character sheets for this Arc truly
set a solid foundation for all the
various Studios to follow but of course
animation requires animators and it was
the key animators he had under him that
were the ones truly responsible for
elevating the episodes he led at this
point in the series maeda's team was
primarily made up of a mix of Junior and
toy animation in-house animators these
included masaki Sato katsuyoshi
nakitsuru takio IDE and Hisashi iguchi
four phenomenal towns of which you may
have even heard of already Sato and
nakasuro especially produced some of the
most phenomenal character art during
this portion of the series truly taking
Dragon Ball out to a whole new level
while aguchi and iide were still more
than capable of producing striking
artwork their talents for actual
movement were where they really shun and
you can see that in their seriously
Dynamic output but on the whole Junior
were very much an art driven team and so
it's no surprise that so many of those
beloved close-ups come from this very
team the level of fidelity found across
their episodes is honestly insane if I
could draw like masaki Sato I would die
a happy man however Dragon Ball's big
appeal is in its fights and when it
comes to spectacular battles that is
where the iconic Studio sagasha comes in
whatever iconic bow comes to mind from
this Arc it almost certainly comes from
the team at This Magnificent Studio led
by tomokichi Takeuchi in this Arc
sagasha was compiled of four main
talents at this stage Yoko izuka masako
Mizumi and most importantly Masahiro
shimanuki and kazuya hisada although
Mizumi and Azuka absolutely add value to
their team particularly arcs I'll cover
in the future it's primarily shimanuki
and hisada who are just mind-blowingly
good here an anime arguably the most
iconic moments of this Arc shimanuki's
work in sagasha's first Z episode is so
strong there's a real powerful rigidity
to his work and his artwork is honestly
insane but when you move forward
throughout the arc you'll see he animate
some of the most incredible parts of
Goku vs Vegeta 2 including that famous
beam struggle nobody draws debris quite
like this man he really is something
else here although kazuya hasada is
often seen as an equal to shimanuki and
in terms of skill he 100 is he's
actually his Junior when it comes to the
industry standing at this point having
only been promoted to key animator with
Z's fourth episode in spite of this
however his early work on this series
still manages to be excellent filled
with the great and dynamic movement
he'll eventually become known for and by
the time the climax rolls around he's
delivering some truly breathtaking work
now I think what's cool is that Takeuchi
the animation supervisor for segasha at
this point is a pretty talented animator
in his own right and found plenty of
time to produce his own strong
contributions to the series with a very
animation focused brain he'd also quite
often let his star talents under him
shine with minor or no corrections to
their work and well recognizing the
talent of those under you and knowing
when to correct and when not to is a
very important skill and not want every
supervisor understands unfortunately
introducing shindo production named
after its supervisor here mitsubo shindo
is certainly someone with a very
distinctive style and a completely
unwavering touch when it comes to
Corrections if you work under him well
you're absolutely getting your work
redrawn to look like his regardless of
how good it looked in the first place
and well the people under him at this
point are teruhisariu Noriko shibata and
a very famous name these days tadayoshi
yamamuro as a result of shindo's
Corrections and because the studio
aren't hugely animation oriented at this
point it's difficult to pinpoint
particular staff with 100 certainty in
this Arc but I think it's at least
interesting to look at shindo style it
is extremely angular to the point that
it really stands out against the
episodes that surround them it's not bad
or anything but it sure is at odds with
maida's design sheets and even
toriyama's own work for this era next up
is Studio last house for all intents and
purposes last house is the backbone of
Dragon Ball Z regardless of anything I
will say about their quality their
existence is pivotal and they animate
the highest number of episodes in this
series by a mile often allowing
elongated schedules for other Studios
episodes the team was led by masayuki
uchiyama who well let's just say their
evolution across this series might not
result in them having the best
reputation but their work on this Arc is
actually solid thanks to my Ada's
rounder designs here meshing well with
uchiyama's own blobier style under him
are some pretty substantial players in
the Dragon Ball World though Akio catada
Katsuya seki taichiro Ohara and naotoshi
shida it's the latter who carry this
team like no other Ohara is a master of
movement especially with vehicles in
this Arc for some reason shida is
likewise a real powerhouse of an
animator and you almost definitely know
his name already thanks to his crazy
popular output these days you can really
see the beginning beginning of that
famous style creeping through in his
early work here also I mean it's been 30
years and he still draws ears the exact
same way in spite however of this Talent
under him uchiyama does often find
himself criticized for his episodes
thanks to his animation Corrections
while he sometimes does make work
arguably worse even the ones where
they're an improvement tend to look
quite flat and amateur looking as he
doesn't have particularly great line
confidence with his own drawings it's a
very similar tale with the next Studio
too Studio live Yukio ebizawa leads the
charge here and while he's a better
animator then uchiyama his style at this
point in the series is bizarre to say
the least he has perhaps the largest
variety of animators under him across
this Arc and so listing them all
probably isn't the most realistic until
they stabilize later but I do want to
highlight tomiya Edith as a particular
standout and unfortunately someone who
also serves to demonstrate how strange
ebizawa's Corrections can be I mean look
at this the impact of the pose is so
much improved but what a bizarre style
that totally shifts it off model from
the on model original and that's
basically what you get when it comes to
ebizawa and that brings us to the final
well it's not really a studio actually
it's a single person but katsumi aoshima
this man is a beast and largely produced
his episodes on his own with the
exception of some small help from the
likes of hideko Okimoto and if you
haven't noticed I think solo animators
are awesome not only does it take insane
skill to animate an entire 26 minute
long episode almost entirely by yourself
but it really lent itself well to a
production's health being able to slot
yourself into a show at any given time
to allow other teams more time to work
on their episodes is invaluable and well
that speed is worth a lot there was once
an animator with that kind of speed who
did so much work in a given year that
they made more money than the head of
the studio and bought a Porsche how's
that for reward for work Hey Porsche
it's longer and okay that's quite the
mixed bag of our roster I've just now
outlined and yet this Arc is still an
excellent bit of television and well
that's because of course animation isn't
the only thing that makes for good TV a
good director is pivotal especially a
series director the one in charge of the
overall approach to the show for Dragon
Ball Z this was handled by Daisuke
initio for the majority of its run
initio had already been a part of the
original Dragon Ball series alongside Dr
slump director minoru okazaki as the
higher ups weren't convinced okazaki was
fit to lead an action-oriented series
like Dragon Ball alone and uh with a
series like Dragon Ball Z being so
insanely action driven okazaki just
wasn't really needed anymore sorry bud
so initio took the reins and kicked off
the series with a bang with a team of
very competent regular directors under
him too and the most extraordinary of
all has to be yoshihiro ueda this man is
just absurd remember when I said segasha
was the go-to studio for the incredibly
animated episodes well u8 is the one for
direction his storyboards are honestly
Flawless Chuck of creative angles Beyond
toriyama's own paneling and filled with
really seriously impressive lighting
choices this man knows how to set a mood
genuinely like any of those spectacular
episodes you remember from this part of
the series were probably directed by him
and if they weren't it was nishio the
pair are just spectacular together
and the knee but and so with
introductions over the story of Dragon
Ball Z's production is really just
beginning keep the names mentioned in
mind going forward too as with each
video in this series we'll be taking a
look at who else joins The Fray their
standout episodes and how each of those
Studios begins to evolve and Blossom or
in some cases even devolve and so now
with the animation stage set I think the
setting is perfect for
this world
Goku vs Vegeta my friends this is
arguably the greatest fight in all of
Dragon Ball arguably the most iconic
battle in all of Japanese Manga and
Anime and for me it is the single most
influential and important fight scene
I'll ever watch why because this is the
very first time I ever saw Dragon Ball
however if we push aside my internal
biases for a split second I think
there's a lot of Merit to the suggestion
that this is a story known for having
some of the best fight scenes in anime
and this could very well be Dragon
Ball's finest sure it might not hit the
iconic highs of the Frieza vs Goku fight
or excite Millions around the world like
cells but what this fight does better
than any other in my opinion is do
everything and I do mean everything
right one of the first things I noticed
when reading this fight was how Toriyama
liked to play with characters
positioning to invite tension and to
establish a sense of hierarchy which is
perfectly fitting for a fight scene
designed to explore the themes of class
the mission statement of the fight is
reiterated right from the outset quote
on this planet we know that even the
lowest born can outdo the elite if they
work hard enough says Goku in response
to that Vegeta says now I'll show you
the wall you could never scale with hard
work alone this difference in world view
is specifically what this fight is about
Vegeta sees himself as higher than Goku
and thus Toriyama reflects this inflated
sense of authority onto Vegeta by
positioning him physically higher up
than Goku during the beginning standoff
he's seen as slightly higher reflecting
Vegeta's confidence however after that
first exchange ends with Vegeta clearly
getting the better of it that confidence
is validated and grows Vegeta is
naturally the stronger of the two and is
positioned even higher again up until
now it has been very rarely seen that
Goku is the weaker of the two fighters
in any given Arc heck the purpose of
some of those early tournament arcs was
specifically to follow other characters
as they navigate solutions to Goku's
obvious strength advantages but this Arc
establishes Goku as the clear weaker of
the two not as a swerve at the end of a
battle-hired thought but instead at the
beginning why because now with the
strength question having been answered
All That Remains left for Goku to lean
on are the attributes he has that
separate him specifically from the likes
of Vegeta and those traits are the
techniques he's learned and the
friendships he's forged I didn't realize
this small detail on my first
read-through but during Goku's bout with
Napa there's an instance where he takes
his blast head-on or should I say a
chest on hands up in the air with his
key and ghee absorbing the blast as if
it were nothing seeing this made me
recall what King Kai also said to Goku
about his ghee when he was gifting it to
him towards the end of their training
before he left that being that it could
deflect small attacks symbolically the
ghee he's wearing represents the first
line of defense against the Saiyans from
his friends and in this first flurry
with Vegeta it gets torn to rags proving
that Vegeta is going to be a real tough
opponent to overcome even with all that
sets Goku apart from him and in this
moment with the appropriate stressors on
Goku now we get to measure what makes
him special against a character like
Vegeta and interestingly this pushes
Goku in ways he's never been pushed
before it's an incredible surge of
energy but one that comes with its own
drawbacks both literally and
figuratively through Vegeta's own
Furious reaction and counter notice how
at the beginning he was positioned as
this ever looming figure looking down at
The Wretched lower class offspring that
Goku represented but now Goku brought
Vegeta to his knees forcing Vegeta's
hand in one of the best and most
effective symbolic clashes from this
fight soaring high into the sky the
prince of all Saiyans the elite of the
elite burning brighter than Goku could
ever possibly imagine looking down from
on high the self-professed most powerful
in the universe and right beneath him as
the only line of defense between the
Earth and certain destruction stands
Goku alone and exhausted
but Goku isn't alone
he never was
[Music]
erupting in a violent torrent of power
tenacity and tremendous energy Goku goes
to use his Ace his most reliable
technique the Kamehameha it surges from
his palms to block Vegeta's Earth's
shattering attack across this incredible
journey from the very first Arc all the
way to today Goku has met some of the
most incredible people and learned even
more incredible Feats and techniques
from them and fittingly the technique
that he first learned from the Earth's
Defender is what once again acts as a
shield both for him and the planet he
once defended but symbolism isn't all
there is here in fact I think this is
where fighting as a mechanic Peaks for
Dragon Ball personally where the future
might yield more iconic and memorable
moments snapshots in history like Goku's
initial transformation on Namek orc the
various forms of fusion which gave rise
to tons of speculation and fan out over
the years it's this period of dragon
Ball's action that plays host to three
new techniques that all share a common
entry that is perfect for building
tension in the heart of combat and this
commonality these techniques all share
is risk versus reward in other words
this fight is the final culmination of
Goku's martial arts training
specifically where fights after will be
host to Goku overcoming his physical
limits in terms of power and strategy
Goku vs Vegeta is the last hurray for
Goku the martial artist
so let's take a look at this fight under
the microscope to see just how it ticks
and how the techniques used emphasize
the ideologies and strengths of the
respective Fighters but let's get
something straight from the outset
Walking right up to Vegeta in the first
place and asking his friends to dip was
a recipe for disaster for Goku Goku is
objectively when it comes to Raw data
much weaker than Vegeta he's slower
physically inferior currently and can't
even rely on his battle like you or
tenacity like he usually does to make up
the difference because just like him
Vegeta is very experienced and clever so
where does Goku look when he's out of
options well if you think back across
all of Dragon Ball you need to ask only
one question what does Goku always want
to do to fight strong opponents in order
to get stronger it's a very simple
desire and one you might not think is
too dissimilar to vegetas however there
is a subtle difference to their
respective goals that result in them
being total opposites while Vegeta wants
to be the strongest Goku wants to be
stronger Vegeta's end goal is him
standing Atop The Mountain Goku doesn't
have an end goal a destination nothing
Beyond simple but consistent improvement
over time it's a lesson that was
reinforced unto him through his grandpa
Gohan and indeed Master roshi in early
Dragon Ball that he should keep training
keep learning keep improving because
there will always be someone else
stronger around the next Corner unlike
Goku Vegeta's worldview has a very
simple and clear hierarchy structure one
within which he sees himself sitting
atop of in this very first fight Vegeta
refers to himself as the strongest in
the universe which whether he's correct
or not reflects a belief that according
to Vegeta there isn't anything he can
learn from anyone simply because he's
already better than them by his own
Birthright the difference between
between these two characters means that
Goku is always eager to seek out
training and chitlage from Wise Masters
while Vegeta isn't
[Music]
the kaio-ken
developed and taught to him by King Kai
this technique proved to be what kept
Goku in the fight initially magnifying
the damage he could deal along with an
explosion of speed this move too came
packed with a massive amount of recoil
in his body when he pushed himself too
far using it so much so that by the time
the first significant section of the
fight had concluded a simple tap on the
back from yajirobi was enough to leave
him screaming the quote power management
side of this fight against Vegeta is
worth contrasting with the most recent
big Clash of Piccolo vs Goku in that
fight Goku had spent years mastering
control over his body and key and was
able to let loose immense power without
even breaking so much as a sweat I mean
at the very end of the fight he still
had that unreal flurry of attack to
unfold on Piccolo and him being worn
down was a direct result of the damage
Piccolo had been dealing to him but here
with Vegeta he is having to go nuclear
and burn through his energy Reserve at a
rapid rate to even compete it goes a
long way to show just how dire things
truly are the beam struggled Goku
engaged in was a wonderful culmination
of all of these traits I'm talking about
leveraging his own tenacity while
combining the techniques passed down to
him by roshi and King Kai respectively a
short-term win for tremendous long-term
loss in order to put Vegeta in his place
momentarily a place where Vegeta was
forced to reconsider his worldview and
he didn't like that oh my God
the ozaru the ozaru in this context is
the Thematic opposite to Goku's Kaioken
in many respects not something passed
down to him or taught not something
which came with its own risk versus
reward metric to consider but a simple
times 10 multiplier to his own already
immense power many of you might point
out that this isn't exactly a new
technique to the series and it's obvious
why anyone would think that I mean it's
being used a number of times across the
story from the very first Arc all the
way to the middle of this one with Gohan
however the important distinction here
is that unlike every other time in the
series Vegeta is in full control he's
not a wild beast Cutting Loose on a
random area he's very clearly capable of
much more specific movements defensive
Maneuvers and even speech unlike Goku's
techniques there's virtually no downside
to this move from Vegeta well apart from
the jab to his own Pride for leading to
resort to such a measure in the first
place against someone as lowly as
Kakarot with all of that that said this
technique released by Vegeta while it
wasn't his intention unconsciously this
might have been one of the most
significant blows to Goku's emotional
state I've seen and certainly for me the
single most tragic and sad instance in
all of the manga a moment that drags our
minds back to the very first Arc of
Dragon Ball there's a rather large chunk
of Goku's life we aren't privy to the
story itself starts off with Goku
already 11 years of age living alone in
a small house in the mountains praying
to the four-star ball he sees as his
grandfather it's his only family and at
the end of the first Arc we as an
audience discover the truth when Goku
begins talking about the Moon and what
his grandpa used to tell him about it we
put two and two together then and he
transforms but the dramatic irony of all
of this has been that through all the
damage he's caused it's all being
unconscious a terrible truth that has
been hidden from Goku for the longest
time and were reminded of this at the
very beginning of this Arc too when
roshi asks if Gohan has ever acted
strangely around a full moon following
the discovery of his tail and so now as
Vegeta transforms before him it triggers
a very early memory of Goku's one that
took place long before the beginning of
this story a moment in time where his
Grandpa would tell him about monsters
that would come out at night Goku's
first words upon seeing this fully
transformed State I've heard of Apes
like you you killed my grandpa this
Vegeta produced
produce I've seen Goku work through one
that causes him to lip say that he can't
defeat this monster that he can't save
the Earth and one that leads him to
somewhat accept his fate when he says
that he'll apologize to his grandpa when
he gets to Heaven it's a truly horrific
Place Goku finds himself psychologically
but he has one last Ace up his sleeve to
try and in order to make space to
attempt it once again Goku leverages a
technique he learned from another dear
friend
sure
the Genki Dharma the Genki Dharma is the
most symbolic technique presented in
this Arc one that intrinsically tied to
the messaging and themes contained
therein if there was ever a combination
of techniques and circumstances that I
would grind Toriyama a 10 out of 10 4
when it comes to execution and
storytelling it would be his design of
the Kaioken the Genki dama and the ozaru
all mixed together following their
bodies being brutalized and ravaged by
the effects of the Kaioken Vegeta and
Goku are forced to take vastly different
approaches that reflect their respective
ideologies in other words because Goku
used the Kaioken Vegeta needed to use
the ozaru and Goku then therefore needed
to use the Genki dhamma two techniques
that when used in conjunction with one
another create some of the most tense
and exciting sequences I've ever read in
a manga vegito's ozaru grants him
enormous power speed and perfect control
of his faculties whereas Goku's
genkidama while thankfully light on the
effort he needs to expel from from his
body to utilize it forces Goku into the
most compromising position possible one
where he has his guard completely down
and one which forces him to take his
attention away from the literal giant
monster in the arena before him it's an
extraordinary and exciting sequence of
believable cause and effect in what is
quite literally the darkest encounter
Goku has ever faced and when he rolled
his last Dice and it came up Snake Eyes
his legs are crushed he admits defeat
and after firing the last remaining bit
of energy he has right into Vegeta's eye
there and then resigns himself to death
I've never seen Goku like this
but again Goku is never alone
[Music]
versus Vegeta
now this section oh my God this section
okay whoa okay when Dragon Ball is at
its best I don't think there are very
many manga that can compete at least
when it comes to combat it's next level
the storytelling the emotion the tension
the swerves the drama oh my God the
drama the conclusion to this Arc is
utterly spectacular and not only could I
not think of a single thing I would
change whenever I read it I'm always
taken aback by how dumbfoundingly well
executed and exciting it always is the
Genki Dharma was what Goku believed was
his last resort but in actuality there
was always one other Ace hiding up his
sleeve his allies and his loved ones a
number of times throughout this Arc it
subtly brought up how much Goku's allies
friends family and even enemies value
him from Roshi's passing comment about
how everyone worked together to gather
the dragon balls when they discovered it
was he who had passed to Piccolo's kind
words about him on his deathbed there's
something about Goku who he is now
actually that attracts people to him
people who can help who want to help and
those that will lay down their lives to
protect him because they know he can and
has done the very same for them when
Vegeta releases the fake Moon into the
sky Krillin and Gohan notice as they
near kame house but it isn't Krillin who
turns back first a Gohan the youngest
and by far the most terrified and
unsuited to this environment was the
first person to choose to come back to
help at the first sign of irregularity
there's something to that that's just so
damn powerful to me and when they land
to find yajirobi krillin's strategy
seems like a terrific one with Gohan
once again despite being the most
non-confrontational naturally he's the
one that's tasked with getting the
attention of Vegeta and he succeeds
oh my God okay I cannot begin to
describe to you how ten-year-old Mark
might have felt while watching this for
the first time because Vegeta felt like
a monster to me the likes of which I had
never seen before Goku was down for the
count indefinitely Gohan has a spark of
greatness but he's still no match for
the Saiyan Prince and Krillin is much
the same and at this point in my read
through I genuinely took a step back to
take stock of just how dark this entire
Arc has been Dragon Ball up until now
has had certainly its own fair share of
Darker moments here and there but even
taking that into account this Arc is on
another level entirely Goku dies in the
first few chapters in one of the most
graphic ways the series has seen Gohan
is kidnapped Yamcha is killed brutally
the same goes for chaotsu and the means
with which tenshinan leaves this realm
is one of the most awe-inspiring but at
the same time tragically sad and
pathetic send-offs Vegeta kills his own
partner and accidentally reveals to Goku
the tragic fate of his grandpa and the
role he played in it and following that
Goku resigns himself to death this Arc
is just one horrific event after the
next and as Gohan and Krillin are
staring down the barrel of certain Doom
Toriyama reminds us that we are still
reading Dragon Ball
excuse me
[Music]
I cannot express how perfect of a moment
this is and what could quite possibly be
the single best swerve in the entire
series everything and I mean everything
works so well here yadirobi is shown to
be training along with everyone else
early in the arc he even gets his own
small speaking roles he's shown to be
part of the battlefield where Goku and
Vegeta move to eventually and he's never
seen by Vegeta thus giving credence to
the notion that Vegeta wouldn't expect
him to come and he didn't watching him
frantically Scurry away frightened
immediately after the slice is nothing
short of hysterical leave it to Akira
Toriyama to undercut one of the darkest
and most intense moments from this
series with one of the best most
perfectly timed and placed jokes I've
ever seen committed to paper and it
doesn't ruin the tension it doesn't ruin
the drama because it's still not enough
say what you want about other acts that
came before this one but Vegeta is a
different breed of foe the amount of
times he dusts himself off and keeps
trudging forward would put Michael Myers
to shame nothing seems to stop this guy
like a murderous short and bigoted
Terminator despite referring to his
original size finds himself still to be
the most Superior on the battlefield a
circumstance that while Dyer still
leaves Goku with more options than he
otherwise had originally at his disposal
Gohan needs to step up to the place one
more time and when he does possibly my
favorite part of this entire fight in
terms of psychology and strategy comes
into play
oh yeah
there's a lot to say about this moment
being Goku's or krillins or even gohans
but in reality I think it's a perfect
combined effort of all three Goku the
man who traveled to Helen Back to get
the knowledge the ability to defeat
Vegeta only to fail now has to channel
the technique he was taught and pass it
to the person he trusts more than anyone
else on this planet Krillin a character
that once epitomized the definition of
underhanded jealousy in the series has
grown to become one that recognizes his
own false and shortcomings faster than
anyone else and perhaps to a fault of
all the earthlings Krillin is the only
one that remains that can make any
meaningful difference and being one of
the only two that Goku can pass this
responsibility off to Krillin is his
first choice and in the end he was the
perfect choice his own self-doubt gave
him room to delay the throw long enough
to listen to King Kai's advice and if
not for yajirobi Krillin would have been
the hero of Earth there and then but I'm
so glad he wasn't because what happens
afterwards is even better now alerted to
the danger Vegeta easily dodged the
sphere seeking his evil key now hurtling
towards Gohan he has to act fast the
child that was less than a year ago too
shy and scared to introduce himself
without encouragement now stands in
opposition to the most terrifying man
the Earth and Goku has ever encountered
one that not only threatens their lives
but wishes to torture them all and
what's more he now stands down the
single most powerful attack his own
father's most powerful attack with the
instruction of reflecting it back to
that monster Vegeta this entire sequence
tells its own incredibly Rich story that
enraptured me from start to finish an
arc a story a fight all about how
relying on others is a sign of weakness
now proves to be the most decisive blow
leveled against the most terrifying
entity the Earth has ever been
threatened by an attack that could have
happened had three or four Brave allies
not rallied themselves to defeat a Grace
my God this is the best Arc ever just
when you think this fight is over when
you think there couldn't possibly be
more Akira Toriyama says hold my heat up
and brings out more remarkable swerves
and Revelations like Gohan's tail having
regenerated like Goku's used to back in
the day granted this is a little or very
convenient given the circumstances but
after what we've just seen to me this is
just having fun and the icing on what is
slowly becoming one of the most
delicious cakes I've ever eaten okay
that analogy got a little away from me
there towards the end but what I'm
saying is this story is great sure it
takes some Liberties to make this happen
but it makes up for it because
[Applause]
[Music]
lands the attack Toriyama used the
regenerated tale of Gohan to create
space for another incredibly funny
yajirobi swerve I cannot describe to you
the joys this story makes me feel
yajirobi is a king an unsung MVP of this
story and fittingly what deals the
finishing blow to Vegeta is in a punch a
kick a sword or even an energy blast but
instead the very transformation the
Saiyans have used to conquer so many
other worlds a transformation that
crippled Goku and one that took his
grandpa away from him and In the Heat of
that Savage form amidst all of the chaos
and destruction the reason of Son Gohan
the innate Humanity he represents was
enough to allow him the clarity to
Target Vegeta specifically and Target
him he most certainly did it's a
thrilling turn of events as the last
gasp of Earth's forces resulted in a
roar the likes of which Vegeta narrowly
escapes and that's when it happens he
Retreats but this Retreat and apparent
Victory is cut short by a curious
request of gokus for no other reason
Beyond his own admitted selfish desires
he asks Krillin to spare his life so
that he may one day fight him again and
in the end the ultimate win for Earth
the prevailing of humanity was capped
off with a very Saiyan request from Goku
an aspect of them that will be explored
even further in the next Arc as this
colorful cast of characters we've all
grown so familiar with leave the
comfortable confines of their homes to
venture forth into the dark Starry Sky
above in search for an answer to this
question they've all collectively had
can they bring their fallen friends back
from Beyond can they reach Planet Namek
to secure the namekian dragon balls
without succumbing to the dangers and
Terrors that lurk in deep space tune in
next week to find out but in conclusion
the difficulty in analyzing Dragon Ball
Z like I have today it comes from its
abundance of characters that all
independently deal with their own
Journeys while their respective paths
might intertwine in interesting and at
times incredibly entertaining ways these
are still unique stories to each
respective character that serve to not
only create the cast we discussed today
but also serve to establish the
Infectious and engaging world of Dragon
Ball we all wish we could be a part of
structuring this video such that I gave
enough time to explore the origins of
what this Arc and ultimately what Dragon
Ball was trying to achieve is difficult
and requires careful consideration and
if you feel as though I've glanced over
certain aspects like Goku's first
interaction with his brother acting for
many as the beginning of Goku's road to
accepting his Saiyan ancestry rest
assured I haven't forgotten about that
section and instead have saved that
material for a section I hope to cover
in the next video covering the Frieza
Arc and Goku's Ascension to legend in
the manga industry but in short this is
a story I grew up with and what this
video represents is a view into my mind
and how I perceive understand and see
drag Dragon Ball Z in other words this
is why this story has been the most
influential in my life and why I am
writing this series at all we've
defeated the Saiyans everybody but we
are far from out of the woods yet next
time we travel to Planet Namek and I
can't wait for you all to join me on
that mission too but until then I've
been Mark Fitzpatrick thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]